start collecting these tractors 25 years
ago as you do with one and you restore
that and you get it going and then you
move on and so the collection really
came together over about 25 years some
of them probably the only ones in the UK
the halt in particular is the only
remaining halt that did service in the
First World War
well this is the first tractor I
restored I bought it from a local farmer
for 250 pounds and then send it to an
old pal of mine to restore and that's an
earlier restoration because it was one
that was restored 25 years ago and a 20
over 20 years anyway this is a bit
special because of its provenance I
would think the restoration costs of
that tractor alone were fifteen or
sixteen thousand I don't think for one
moment I still get value back on the
restoration because restoring tractors
like any old piece of equipment is very
costly
it's a rare tractor it was made at L
Stowe in Bedfordshire and it cost new in
1922 three hundred and fifty pounds and
it's known as the soreness and soreness
and Universal G and it's still got the
old wooden toolbox on it with some tools
in it well I'm not getting younger and
my family are not that interested so
I've made my decision
easier in a way and I'd much rather deal
with my affairs in an orderly way before
I popped my clogs like you don't plan to
do that yet or at least I hope not
because I'm looking for another
challenge